the reject nation it's Greg Alva here
and I'm John we're gonna watch the
trailer for the ritual Netflix movie or
show I don't know
I hear it's scary before hopping into
this want to give a shout out to today's
video sponsor that is a Stardust app
people start us as an app that we are
growing and followers every single day
right now loving using it over 120
exclusive posts over there 30-second
reactions for any film TV show or
trailer lot of huge youtubers are on
this app right now a lot of people who
have guest sit on this channel before as
well if we are the first ones to tell
you about this down the app and follow
us first because the Stardust people
need to know were the ones who told you
first followers in any area
[Music]
it's like a horror movie of World's End
was it really quiet it's the forest or
is the bay they don't show you the
nature documentaries is they have a
sense of humor about that's good yeah
open your head expose it expose your
head
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
guys so we're going to talk about it was
a nightmare
weapon to you that got spooked and we
have bad dreams all right
[Music]
oh no oh no dang that's a movie right
whatever is a Netflix I'm never sure
yeah it does look really intense
it looks really it looks like a better
version of Blair Witch Project yeah were
you actually gonna see stuff go down you
might even get some reveals and some
answers and a lot more creepy imagery
yeah this looks like both an intense
horror movie but also a pretty
compelling mystery yes there's a lot of
WTF imagery in this and you know the
whole paranoia of these four dudes lost
out in the woods not trusting each other
when I see trailers like this I usually
think okay the characters are probably
gonna be annoying this one I didn't get
that vibe at all I imagine this probably
gonna be some fun British comedy the
type of British wit banter in here I
know the trailer is not showcasing that
but I've seen these other actors before
at least two of them I've seen comedies
first half hour they're gonna be yes I
imagine that in the first half hour
they're gonna be really setting up these
characters well so you're really
invested in their personalities and the
spooks look really good there's a lot of
great creepy imagery here the animal
even that one naked dude who's like tied
up yeah something going on this woods
that I'm curious to find out what's
going on is the ritual what's happening
to them or is the ritual of them going
on a trip together that's what is taking
the shortcut through the woods you know
a lot of people do it and it never turns
out it's funny you brought that up
earlier I almost felt like this was the
more adult version of a movie about like
I've seen this set up before with
teenagers but now it's you know more ya
ask people so I feel like the tambour
will be a little bit different hopefully
I'm hoping this script is smart in terms
of how people are reacting at things
because one-line kind of hinted at this
is probably a smarter script than a lot
of other kinds of these movies when he
was like I woke up with this and then
the guy was like just denying it and
he's like why do you just deny
everything I say that kind of thing that
awareness makes me go these characters
might be smarter than what we're used to
in these kinds of films and add actual
odds instead of just here's your care
turn note and here's your carry a note
and here's your character yeah this is
the first I've heard of this I think it
looks pretty cool and it's cool for Rafe
spall too because he's you know we've
seen him in so many different supporting
roles especially like a great movie yeah
that's right I see a minute comedies
he's a really good dramatic actor too so
I'm excited to see him lead something
that's both more weighty and also you
know for me or it'd be funny if the
post-credits scene was logan paul
showing up in the forest yeah well
netflix now you are adding so much to my
watchlist on your app damn hey that's a
smart thing to do to get people to
subscribe we're just gonna make sure
that we have top-notch content well you
guys can subscribe to the real rejects
click that notification bell get
notified every time one of our videos is
up and make sure to download and follow
us in the Stardust app people could
really appreciate that I could
appreciate it you could allow you that's
a question you